thank you
[Music]
welcome back to a Monumental episode of
careful boy today we are officially
off the Record
we talk about whatever we want no wow
we do talk about whatever we want as you
guys can see you today we have Mickey
back with us
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] I'm not Attitude Era girl yeah I
want to be a careful boys
an honorary careful it coexists it's
one's a time and temporal thing the
other one is just a lifestyle 2023 might
be something else it's like being Jewish
like one's a religion and like it's also
a culture it's culture and you kind of
don't like you oh [ __ ] he doesn't like
the lifestyle or he doesn't like the
religion or the ethnicity part of it he
doesn't like Jewish
does he like the Attitude Era oh yeah he
subscribed so long as our fans stay
subscribed yeah but 2023 it might be the
gentleman era so we have to know we have
to figure that out in January the
gentleman area
attitude's kind of short then huh are
you calling audibles right now without
meetings yeah we need to have a creative
meeting for this for sure no it's okay I
choose it you all need top hats oh yeah
so it's it's been a while since you've
been here
um that's the believe all women side now
okay
this is the 26. always yeah okay that's
the [ __ ] up biracial NWA side let's go
let's go [ __ ] the police yeah
it's been two years since I've been on
this two years how does it feel to be
back I don't know it feels kind of the
same but different yeah yeah but your
life has changed tremendously the last
two years like you're super focused on
poker now yeah so proud of you it's so
amazing seeing her journey it's so
[ __ ] cool you don't know well I don't
know how like it just happened and uh
and then it just kept happening
what a game plan yeah it's a habit what
was the first because I remember when
you were slowly getting into it you're
like I'm gonna read a book I'm like
really like do it the right way what was
the first like game because you played
poker before right what was the first
game that you're like okay but now it's
not for fun yeah I'm gonna be a poker
player game uh when I went to a public
casino to play it for the first time
like a public Casino so I played like
home a lot of home games and stuff and
then like I played in Vegas once before
but it was a tournament and it was back
in like 2007 and no one knew what they
were really doing and um
I don't know it was like I didn't yeah I
didn't know before in a tournament
that's how you start you just yeah but
but the thing was I didn't even know it
was a tournament I just was thought
because I'd only played home games I
just was like whatever we're playing
poker like I didn't really think about
it I played poker in a tournament when I
first started this is about her right
now eliminated right away though
that's a good story I got eliminated too
right away it was Aces vs Ace King and I
had Ace King and this is all in
immediately it was like she remembers
everything
this is how we're this is what movies
are written about I know this is why I'm
good at poker I remember everything
everyone did pre-flop action on every
hand and I remember whether or not they
did that with two pair or Flash or if
they're bluffing or if the frequencies
which they Bluff they're like I can like
I can they're like Queens Gambit but you
just see cards yeah honestly I mean it's
not as visual but yeah like in my head
yeah that's tight it's like you know
every
I get in front available for socially
like when someone's telling a story and
I'm like that wait that part didn't make
sense or that there was a hole in that
story or this like little Minor Detail
was off or that's inaccurate that people
are like shut the [ __ ] up I'm trying to
tell a story it doesn't matter that all
works with poker because it's just like
it's like looking at people's stories
what kind of story they're trying to
tell and whether or not it makes sense
and if it makes sense then I believe
them if it doesn't make sense even like
a little bit doesn't make sense what's
an example you're [ __ ] Steve she's gonna
know your whole track record this is
what I'm telling you guys no you left
the toilet seat up you [ __ ] dude
I'm telling you on a Wednesday at 7 48
a.m that's hard Gaslight autism
I think that helped too I think those
episodes
embracing my office is really awesome
last night you were definitely The
Attitude Era last night you were in a
hand against a dude and and he was he
was bluffing you right what was going on
which one you're telling me I don't
remember
all the time how did you know he was
bluffing like okay so there's like
little things like like let's say bed
sizing toes like everyone has a tail and
I just observed for like the first like
I don't know 15 minutes of sitting at a
table and to get everyone's kind of feel
of how they play the game and so like
this guy he always bets kind of small
when he has it to get value out of you
out of like your hands everybody would
come out of it he's betting big to try
to get you off your hand so I just call
him down when he bets big if I have
something that like a hero call you know
if I have something small but if you bet
small and I don't have a strong hand
then I fold so it's like I believe him
when he's betting small but I don't
believe him when he's betting big
because he just gave his all his toes
away so his story didn't make sense when
he got big whoa so it's kind of like
that and you keep track of everybody's
thing yeah at the same time that's cool
what do you think that guy is thinking
like this [ __ ] [ __ ] is on to me
[Laughter]
she's a chick they're all like oh this
[ __ ] doesn't know the [ __ ] going on
yeah where's
I pretend I'm not paying attention a lot
too I have my headphones on but no
music's playing and like I'm on my phone
I also try to get people to talk a lot
if I'm not sure if they have it I get
them to talk I start like calling out
[ __ ] like what do you have [ __ ]
floors pack of Threes you can't possibly
have jacked it and like and I see like
the way they react even like their
breathing changes like you can pick up
on that and I don't know yeah and if
they seem pretty confident or like they
seem unbothered by my questions they're
probably strong but if they kind of like
they don't know how to react they start
breathing heavier I'm like I'm like all
right I had to transcribe you dude I'm
just like oh my God I feel like I'm so
nervous right now I can't I can't give
any tells
do you think there's something that
separates high-level players from like
regular casual players yeah absolutely
and what would that be mostly balancing
the ranges like being able to balance
when they have a good hand in their
Bluffs like and being able to Bluff at a
high enough frequency so it's more
subtle instead of like really don't get
any reads on them yeah so if they're
autistic as well too they're like pretty
much if they're fully autistic is that
what is the autistic championships yeah
there's like the highest levels
honestly the community is all ADHD and
autistic like
one or the other
or both if you're playing poker and you
don't want anyone to give your reads you
just have to be neutral all the time huh
yeah like it's a lot of the way GTO play
which is Game Theory optimal is like is
being able to balance all of that whoa
yeah that's so crazy what causes Joe
have would that help if you were playing
with something like this or is that
considered cheating people do play with
sunglasses but I think you should
probably tell by how they breathe it's
not even like I don't even care about
the eyes people think the eyes are so
important but it's really your breathing
pattern your neck pulsating and your
hands like they get more fidgety if I do
this the whole game yeah their leg
starts bouncing like a lot of them
because they're [ __ ] ADHD they're
like they when they're bluffing their
leg [ __ ] bounces out of [ __ ]
control if I do this the whole time then
it doesn't matter it's called security
is there any time someone's doing too
much that you're like I can't get a read
because he's just constantly doing [ __ ]
is that everything no wow see someone
doesn't get the game but you also can't
do that for like eight hours you can't
they can't sustain that yeah you can't
have like a harmonica
you know what they try to do sometimes
people like that they talk a lot and
then uh when they're in a when they're
really strong they or they're trying to
Bluff or whatever it is they try to
mimic what their normal behavior is but
it's like it's like hyper oh my God
[Laughter]
Steve describes your skill he really
makes it sound like highly raid Manish
do you have like he's talking about like
a disability he uses vernacular like
that okay that's funny but like is it
true I'm mostly talking about how I'm
kind of the Tom Cruise cool guy yeah but
we know that's true
but like do you have do you think like
uh do you have any other social quirks
outside of Poker that seem like you're
autistic well yeah that like pointing
out the gaps in store you know how
annoying I've been to people who like
he's had to train me to stop doing that
because I'd be like they'd be like yeah
so it was like 4 P.M I'm like no no it
was 2 p.m when you did that and that
doesn't matter it doesn't matter to the
story I'm like but it's just inaccurate
like
shut us all down you're a good
eyewitness then to a cop if like you saw
a crime you should be a detective is it
technically like uh so it's almost as if
like you memorize all the details but
then some of them don't really like
affect the story but those still like
hey that was an actor I gotta call it
out yeah so there's there's that they're
an accuracy
there's also like um you like being able
to eliminate things like uh you know
in in the game when JK Party The Who The
what's up are you who am I I like always
could guess it like really fast and
people at JK party were like she's
cheating she saw the car but it really
is this skill of being able to eliminate
things very quickly so when someone's
betting and I'm like they wouldn't have
opened they they could were they trying
to represent six nine off like they
wouldn't have opened with that from
early position like it doesn't make
sense to the story like deductive
reasonings yeah I'm like I'm like well
I've taken away six nine I'm taken away
um Jack 10. I like there's nothing else
you could have that beats me so I call
you know so but you're doing it really
fast because if they're opening from a
certain position they have a certain
range of hands that they're opening with
and it's usually tighter the earlier the
position is so if an early position is
trying to represent some junk ass hand
it just doesn't work but if a later
position is representing that I kind of
believe them I'm like well they don't
have they probably don't have the better
hands but they might have this junk ass
hand so so how is that ability and
mentality like either improved or like
uh complicated your um relationship with
Steve it just has not changed it has
probably taken the spotlight
that's true on the poker that is more
fruitful you're like thank God for a
place off my case yeah take the
attention away from the toilet seat for
[ __ ] sake
there was this funny uh situation where
um like I met you here ages ago I think
I was coming in as a guest and you were
just leaving that day and that's like
when I officially like met you yeah and
then we shook with the left hand and
then this other time everything but I
don't remember that very forgettable and
then there was other time I ran into you
guys at like the Hollywood Cemetery
during like the Friends reunion special
yeah yeah yeah and then I was like hey
what's up how's it going and then like
uh I was good I went to go say hi to you
yeah and then you you went like this and
started looking at stuff and I went okay
yeah yeah I don't I don't like you I
remember thinking like the point of the
story I was like was I being weird and
then and then as I like became a regular
here and got to know Steve and he was
describing you I was like oh maybe like
you sound like maybe you're just kind of
like yeah [ __ ] and yeah so how do
you like take it personally so that's
why you're like yeah are there any other
social clerks that you have uh
you're trying to get an answer it's not
me right people you don't like yeah
um well I mean 80 I mean Joe would know
what the ADHD it was like uh I'm
undiagnosed like you're kind of like
he's maintaining like if something's not
hyper focused on you're just like all
over the place like I'm in my own world
most of the time yeah thinking about 1
000 other things than what is in front
of me but if there's something that can
take all of my attention then it has my
whole Focus like I am not thinking about
anything else but that um so it's one or
the other not to make it sound uh worse
but sometimes like I'm like hey babe
you've been stuck for a little while and
she's like oh yeah okay and she's like
been standing there she's just been
staying in there for like 45 minutes
yeah it's like a long time wow just tell
her nothing no she's like doing she's
like fixated on something visualizing
what dining room table I want in that
space and like whether or not I should
paint the walls and like what that color
would look like and yeah I get really
frustrated though 32 minute Mark and
you're like I'll give her one more
minute well no because sometimes if I do
it if I do it too early then she's like
yo I'm in my thing demand do anything
but then if it's if it's been enough
time where she just needs me to bump her
out of it it's like tomorrow oh yeah
okay hey Alexa time what Nikki's doing
it's like a screensaver he's gonna move
the mouse yeah yeah basically but dude
um you know knowing that like it helps
me because I know how to how to like
talk to her about all that stuff yeah uh
I get really frustrated with that too
with myself because I can't like time
manage well because I think like oh I
have like three hours and then like I'm
like where the [ __ ] did two hours go
because I was just spaced out like
thinking about oh I should I should do a
drone shot of me in the jacuzzi wood and
then I should do a video about it about
like because there's a lot of things I
want to talk about this jacuzzi but that
I've found out over the past years and
people might want to know about that if
they're buying an inflatable jacuzzi
oh [ __ ] it's nothing to do with my day
it's just gone and I'm like wait oh no I
had so much time it's gone so with such
a good memory how do you keep forgetting
you already bought pillows for the bed I
don't follow true it's it's out of spite
now
premeditated
he said about you
I I didn't know that he was gonna air
our Dirty Laundry about our marriage
being so terrible rocks
um when I met Steve and we first started
dating he had an air mattress with one
pillow which was sweat stained no
pillowcases
no sheets no sheets oh God on the
plastic blanket that was a fleece
blanket not even a comforter he's a
simple man still [ __ ] him and I still
came back
I had to see what it was like because I
never [ __ ] a guy on an air mattress
before I never had never slumped it that
hard
one pillow then I upgraded this man's
life and this is thanks I get yeah I'm
sorry I made your life cushy I am too
why did I miss the simple things
[Laughter]
put your air mattress back God damn
complicated so many [ __ ] pillows
stains all those pillows so I could keep
having to buy more
I'm a man I sweat you were being both
but as a guy that's luxurious because he
said he has two pillows he's like not
one okay coolest thing real quick quick
pitch to the boys this air mattress
thing it was a suitcase that like
unpacked and then you plug it in it was
really cool
it blows itself up and the legs go on
the ground it [ __ ] elevates oh
there's legs
yo now he complains about a queen size
bed we go to an Airbnb he's like oh it's
on the Queen's side I'm like bro so hey
show to you full-size air mattress like
bro can you even fit on there that's too
small it was too small but you know what
it was really nice for your trunk
right now
that whole image of the sweat stain and
the one pillow that's an unironic thing
you set up it's 100 fact it's 100 I wish
I had a picture of what I sacrificed
it's just dudes being dude to get to
this point this is blowing out
I still sleep on the couch
upgraded from
you're making us feel bad
nowadays they have some real sick ass
air mattresses have you ever been like
to Walmart or something you see that
I've ever been to Walmart
since people here have been to Walmart
you know Hawaii Walmart's really cool
yeah it's kind of cool yeah it has a lot
of tourist stuff there you can get those
Mac nut chocolates yeah what are some of
your other favorite uh products from
Walmart
tricycles they're really affordable I
think well I would never get the
stability
exactly
it's pricing out tricycles yeah it's
really cheap compared to bicycles that's
a deal Mickey where do you buy your
pillows from uh most uh mostly not well
mostly target yeah
my favorite is drunk pillow shopping I
go the truck I get drunk go to Target I
put all the pillows in there and then I
go Nikki you gotta put some pillows back
you gotta put them back and I make
myself in a shopping cart is that was
that was there any fact to that when he
said you'd be daisy chaining four of
carts putting all this [ __ ] like that
that's fast that's fast yeah it is facts
plus is a great store but that's not all
pillows that's like lamps and stuff too
oh that's okay so it's a whole thing
yeah it's like well like visually you're
pulling one with your legs
pillows two couches like shoes to an
outfit is that what like what's the like
what's the concept of pillowing what's
what's the concept of a pillow I was
like fart he's like what's up what is
pillow besides like all songs
up on the floor like you don't have to
wear a nice watch you can wear a regular
watch it is like that it's like
accessorizing your furniture yeah it's
like I yeah and I never was into it okay
here's the thing I was never a pillow
person never thought I would be a pillow
person didn't understand it but then
Pinterest came about and I was like yeah
I was like I get it damn these people
damn them to help okay before it was
like catalogs like okay that's
unreasonable I'm never gonna get to that
level but then these regular ass people
were doing
[Laughter]
so they got became a competition what
else did you get for six bucks yeah you
want to talk about the savings
sponsor the customers at Costco
the concept because we were struggling
with a little bit of having the tray at
the foot of the bed with the candle in
the book that nobody reads it's [ __ ]
art it's okay so here's you could have
just said the coffee table it looks like
okay
on the bed I never even used to make my
bed and then I was like I'm gonna be the
pro one day it was like 2015. I was like
I'm an adult it's a new year I wanna I
wanna be a type of person that makes my
bed you know I heard that like really
sets the day you know and we were work I
was working at home full time and I was
like I really like I walk in my bedroom
a lot and that's the other thing people
were like you don't even go when you
break no I go in my bedroom a lot I walk
out my bedroom a lot and I like walking
in it's like ah it looks nice in here so
I started making my bed but it didn't
look like the catalog so it didn't make
me happy it's like why not even do that
work it doesn't even look good it just
[ __ ] stupid plain ass bed it doesn't
look good let them know so then I
started adding pillows and I was like
this [ __ ] fills my heart with joy
those are all Rejoice yeah you [ __ ]
dicks
those books on the tray they hold a
candle and it smells good yeah
senses when I walk okay okay visually
yes like sensually I'm in love with my
environment essentially I get it that's
a big deal I get it now
that she explains it dude you guys are
all sentenced doesn't that sound nice
narcos on the wall
this dude [ __ ] velcro's a monkey
picture on it not just one monkey
picture many monkey pictures
the safety strip was right yeah because
his chair keeps on hitting it on one
side yeah cause I'm too close in the
corner he's like
he told me the story he's like he's out
he's our place he's like dude your chair
is way too [ __ ] close to the court
I'm like nah that's fine and I keep
hitting the [ __ ] button I keep
hitting my monkey pictures off so that's
why it's just the velcro strip on one
side and then the frame on the other
that's such a classic guy shape like
you're causing a problem continuously
but you're like no it's fine that's fine
well they're called command strips not
velcro
oh I didn't know that was military
Bridge dude it is it is show some
perspective this this adhesive it's like
they make hooks they make it you know
it's the it's actually the double-sided
adhesive and you have the velcro command
strips this is [ __ ] velcro this is
the the hole in the store it's like
inaccurate
you tried to correct me and I was right
but is it the command brand it's the
command brand it is it's like red button
it's a velcro the velcro version Oh we
should keep talking about okay well
bought some I never used how can we get
deeper into this yeah well they're they
don't have do they work well they don't
have command picture frames that's the
biggest problem that's demonstrated by
the story I bought a pack of 20 that I
never used it actually worked well if
you stay within the weight capacity yeah
so if you buy the 2.2 reel dude the 2.5
pounds
time frames it's not gonna work this is
for our listeners what products do you
like at Walmart I'm an art collector but
I never hung it up because I bought the
command strips and I was worried is that
on the wall only or maybe on the bed I
have it in a stack and uh getting it
ready put some in our place too they
actually work good no okay I still want
to know what else can you get it at
Walmart dude at Walmart the first
company that makes us anything where I
can hit it with my [ __ ] computer
chair and it doesn't go off the wall I'm
buying it it's called a nail hmm
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]